it's a debate that's raged for millennia
which aspects of our reality are
absolute
and which are merely
relative
when it comes to the concept of motion
two physicists held opposing views
and to resolve the differences in their
philosophies
they invoked a simple thought experiment
that involved
well
a bucket
and some water
but does this experiment really prove
that motion has absolute meaning or does
it actually demonstrate the opposite
that motion is just a relative construct
[Music]
today we'll pit these two thinkers
against one another to find out
this is dialect with newton versus mock
the bucket experiment
when newton introduced his
groundbreaking theories in the late
1600s he framed them against a
mathematical background that contained
three absolutes
time
space
and motion
time
space and motion
the vulgar conceive these quantities
only in their relation to sensible
objects he wrote
but absolute time
flows uniformly without regard to
anything external
absolute space always remains similar
and immovable
absolute motion is the translation from
one absolute place to another absolute
place
although some were skeptical of these
definitions the success of newton's
theories in describing motion and
gravity gave no real reason for
physicists to question them over the
following centuries
but in the late 1800s the skepticism of
one physicist ernst mock would have an
irreversible impact on the course of
physics
newton has grown unfaithful to his
resolve to investigate only actual facts
mock declared in his signature text the
science of mechanics
the question whether emotion is in
itself uniform is senseless
we reach our ideas through the
interdependence of things upon one
another
in his ensuing critique of newton mach
declared that no one is competent to
predicate things about absolute space or
motion
that they are purely mental constructs
his ideas helped propel a young albert
einstein towards the theory of
relativity
and soon in the wake of relativity's
massive success
two of the three pillars of newton's
absolutes time and space
came crashing down
but today newton's final absolute motion
still stands
that is all our modern theories of
reality are framed against a
mathematical background which posits one
particular type of motion
acceleration as absolute
and although mock was ahead of his time
in realizing that both the ideas of
absolute time and absolute space were
soon to fall
his critique of newton's concept of
absolute motion never experienced
similar validation
and so modern physicists have split into
two camps
those who believe newton's assertion
about absolute motion to be correct and
those who believe mock's critiques will
eventually come to fruition
[Music]
particularly what mock found lacking
about absolute motion was the experiment
cited by newton to justify it
the bucket experiment
newton had observed that if you took a
bucket filled with water
and started to spin it the water inside
would go from being flat to having a
concave shape
according to newton this difference
proved motion was absolute
how exactly
well let's break it down
newton notes that there are exactly two
points over the course of the experiment
that the bucket and the water will be
relatively at rest
[Music]
the first point is before the bucket has
been spun when both the bucket and the
water aren't moving
the second point is after the bucket has
been spun
and its motion having been communicated
to the water via friction the water
takes a concave shape
at this point both the bucket and the
water are spinning at the same rate
together and from the perspective of an
observer who is rotating along with them
the entire apparatus will appear to be
at rest
now according to newton if the observer
in the spinning frame didn't already
know the bucket was rotating
they could deduce it from the fact that
the shape of the water is concave
conversely if we had an observer who was
rotating with respect to the still frame
so that relative to them the bucket and
the flat water appeared to be spinning
they could deduce that the bucket was
actually at rest by the flat shape of
the water
thus the first picture with the water in
the bucket being flat represents
absolute rest
while the second picture with the water
being curved represents absolute motion
distinctions such as these newton argued
always make it possible to distinguish
between motion that is true or real and
motion that is only apparent
but mock fired back that this argument
was too abstract
the centrifugal forces which seemingly
caused the water in the bucket to take
its concave shape aren't produced by an
absolute rotation he argued but by a
rotation relative to the mass of the
earth and the other celestial bodies
[Music]
every statement about motion mock
believed
implicitly carries an abbreviated
reference to the rest of the universe
and thus removing the rest of the
universe from the picture leaves us
unable to define what we mean by motion
in the first place
[Music]
both newton and mock seem to make
compelling points but who is ultimately
right
to resolve this metaphysical face-off
we're gonna have to step into the rink
and get our hands a little wetter with
the bucket experiment
[Music]
first let's ask what actually gives the
water its concave shape
well as our bucket begins to spin the
water inside gets flung outwards towards
the walls
with nowhere else to go this water is
forced to rise
[Music]
gravity however keeps it from rising too
much and as a result the surface of the
spinning water achieves a rotational
equilibrium
next
conservation of energy tells us that in
this state of equilibrium
the kinetic energy of a spinning ring of
water at a distance r from the center of
the bucket will be equal to its
potential energy
mgh
since the velocity of the spinning ring
is simply the angular velocity of the
bucket times the rotation radius
we can see
after a little algebra that the height
of the ring of water is thus
proportional to the square of its
distance from the center of the bucket
meaning the overall shape of the water
will be a parabola
but the height of the water is also
dependent on another parameter the
strength of the nearby gravitational
field g
and if we dial down the strength of that
field to zero
we see that the height of the water goes
to infinity
what this implies is that spinning our
bucket in zero gravity would actually
result in all the water being ejected
from the bucket
[Music]
a fact which tells us something that
newton neglects to mention
that is
that the concave shape of the water is
not just a consequence of the bucket
spinning but rather a consequence of its
spinning in the presence of a
gravitational field
the implication of course is that in the
absence of such a field
the shape of the water's surface no
longer acts as an indicator of
rotational motion
[Music]
of course one could contend that this
doesn't affect newton's argument since
if we spun our bucket in zero gravity
we'd have one picture of total rest and
one picture where our water is flying
all over the place
but newton's objective with the bucket
experiment was not to demonstrate a case
where motion and rest were easily
differentiated
but rather to find a case where motion
and rest appear essentially
indistinguishable and then show that
even in these instances such telltale
differences can always still be found
the problem then is that for the bucket
experiment to fulfill this criteria that
is for there to be a state of rest for
the system which is only apparent
the bucket is required to inhabit a
gravitational field
thus to make his case that true motion
can always be locally distinguished
within a system
newton is actually forced to invoke a
nearby mass external to that system
meaning his experiment could not be
reproduced in the absence of external
matter
since this falls more in line with
mock's argument than it does with
newton's
we're crowning mock the winner of this
first round
likely realizing the bucket experiment
was a little too contextual newton in
his writings offers up a second
experiment
take two globes attached to a cord and
spin them around in a circle about their
center of mass
[Music]
then
by investigating the tension produced in
these chords one could determine the
quantity and direction of the circular
motion
considered even in an immense vacuum
where there was nothing external or
sensible with which the globes could be
compared
now this experiment unlike the bucket
one has the benefit of being able to be
reproduced in the absence of external
matter
but in keeping with the bucket
experiment it offers two states of
apparent rest along with a theoretical
way to measure the difference between
them
to see how this measurement could occur
it might be easier for us to envision
our two masses as attached by a spring
rather than a cord
as the masses rotate centrifugal forces
push them outwards stretching the spring
a stretched spring therefore indicates
absolute rotation
and by measuring how much the spring has
stretched one can determine the exact
magnitude of force causing the rotation
with this simple definitive seeming
argument newton claims the title as our
second round winner
establishing a concept of absolute
motion that could be empirically
verified even in the absence of all
other matter in the universe
who wins the final round
well to find out we need to think about
what the bucket experiment is really
saying
let's recall again that newton's
original argument relied on there being
two distinct points of view of relative
rest
one in which the bucket and water are at
rest with respect to one another and the
water is flat and one in which the
bucket and water are at rest with
respect to one another but the water is
curved
similarly for the masses attached to the
spring in a vacuum in both pictures the
masses and the spring are at rest with
respect to one another but in one
picture the spring is stretched and in
the other it isn't
now the picture of the stretched spring
is supposed to correspond to absolute
motion
but we also have to recall the fact that
the observers in these frames don't know
whether they're spinning or not and
therefore don't have access to
information from the outside that would
indicate to them prior to their
measurements made inside their frame
whether or not their frame is inertial
let's say that besides the spring is a
rod of much stiffer material with
markings along it to indicate the length
between coils of the spring
the observer can then read the markings
to measure the length between coils and
thereby determine how much the spring
has stretched
the question then becomes
how does the observer know whether the
measurement they make corresponds to the
shortest possible length of the spring
or not
for in rotational frames only the
shortest possible length of the spring
or its natural resting length indicates
absolute rest
every other length indicates varying
amounts of rotation
in the bucket experiment only flat water
could indicate absolute rest
but here the problem is trickier here
the observer has to know prior to making
any measurements in their frame
what length corresponds to the natural
undeformed state of the spring
and to know that the observer would have
had to previously have calibrated their
spring rod measuring device in a frame
that was already known to be inertial
such as in a laboratory back on earth
[Music]
only by measuring the resting length of
the spring at a time and place when they
were certain there were no external
forces at work stretching or compressing
the spring could an observer ascertain
what picture of the spring corresponds
to absolute rest
thus even in the empty universe version
of newton's experiment observers would
still have to import information from
inertial frames that existed elsewhere
in order to draw any conclusions about
the state of their motion
that means in one way or another an
observer has to reference an external
environment no matter how distant or
removed this environment is
knowledge of the local system cannot
ultimately be untangled from the greater
environment
[Music]
so what does this mean for newton's
argument
well it means the globes and chord
experiment does not actually meet the
criteria for which newton devised it
the criteria of reproducibility in an
empty universe
and because of that it falls short of
proving absolute motion in the same way
the bucket experiment fell short
it relies on the presence of an external
system in order to demonstrate absolute
motion
and well at least to us
this seems most in keeping with mock's
assertion that all our principles of
mechanics are experimental knowledge
concerning the relative positions and
motions of bodies
now were we to expand newton's argument
to allow observers in our rotating
systems
to retain a memory of how substances and
materials behaved in inertial systems
elsewhere then clearly his case still
stands
and to some degree this must have been
newton's reasoning because obviously an
observer who doesn't know anything about
how buckets or water work wouldn't be
able to draw any conclusions about the
state of their motion from the bucket
experiment either
[Music]
but newton clearly also wanted to prove
knowledge of absolute motion was a
localized phenomenon which would always
reveal itself under careful enough
isolated scrutiny
[Music]
yet if you allow your observers enough
memory
memory of how say springs buckets cords
and water behave elsewhere in other
systems at other times
this is equivalent to expanding the
system of reference beyond a
spatio-temporally localized point of
view
thus newton can't have it both ways
knowledge of absolute motion can't both
be always discernable and always
localized
one of the two has to go
but if we try to preserve localization
at the cost of memory this means
observers could potentially disagree on
their states of motion
with no empirical experiment able to
differentiate between them
on the other hand if we try to preserve
discernibility and require that motion
must always be empirically verifiable
we have to invoke memory sufficient
enough to reference a greater collective
of systems
[Music]
essentially this leaves us with two
primary resolutions to the bucket
experiment one
absolute motion is real and localized
but knowledge of it is not always
possible
[Music]
this is equivalent to saying that
although observers may potentially
disagree on who is or isn't moving
motion is still real and governs how our
universe works
this would however make absolute motion
an unobservable phenomenon
something which physics and science in
general tends to disfavor
two
what we perceive as absolute motion is
actually an emergent property of a
network of systems that cannot
fundamentally be isolated from one
another
meaning motion at some level must
ultimately be relative
so which of these answers is it
does absolute motion have real meaning
outside our mathematical descriptions
or is it simply a poorly defined concept
a relic of dogmatic belief that like
absolute space or absolute time
needs to be fundamentally re-examined
well for the time being it's up to you
to decide
so let us know what you think in the
comments
because
until next time
this has been dialect
thanks for watching
you